what's going on guys this is Rob and in
our video today for April Fool's Day I
figured what better character to talk
about than the Clown Prince of Crime
none other than the Joker himself now
what's going to be really cool about
this video is that we're actually going
to be able to look at the Joker's
continuity look at his history in DC
Comics and in fact trace the popularity
the rise to prominence of Batman comics
as well as the sort of low period and
then this re-emergence of Batman's
popularity by simply just looking at the
Joker because the Joker is a key figure
in the success of Batman's continuity
now and one of the things we know I
guess one of the more common aspects of
the Joker's history is that he had
appeared in Batman issue number one in
1940 now he was created by Bob Kane Bill
Finger and Jerry Robinson but there's
some contesting as to who it was it
actually created who and who it was it
had actually been involved in the
creation of the Joker but what we know
is that in some capacity these three men
were involved now what they were looking
for what DC was looking for it was a way
to basically challenge Batman in a way
that had never been seen before they
wanted to introduce some kind of a
villain that was far beyond anything
that we had seen because keep in mind in
the Golden Age of comics a lot of the
villains that we saw were simply a
reflection of the time they were
villains who were thugs they were
criminals they were I guess maybe bank
robbers and things like that they
weren't really anything that was pushing
the envelope they wanted to do this with
the Joker they wanted to introduce a
villain that would test Batman both
mentally as well as emotionally somebody
that would push him to his limits and so
with the initial introduction of the
Joker and Batman issue number one we saw
this playing out what happens here is
that we actually join a couple who are
listening to a radio broadcast when the
radio broadcast is interrupted by some
man who basically says that at midnight
he's going to kill a man by the name of
Henry Claridge he was actually the mayor
of Gotham and so what happens of course
the police respond to this threat so on
and so forth but when midnight strikes
henry Claridge dies and when he dies he
actually ends up dying with this grin on
his face and what the police do is they
begin investigating the crime scene they
begin looking around and trying to
figure out what
all had happened here then what they do
is they stumble across the safe of Henry
Claridge and they find what they believe
to be the diamond that Henry Claridge
had owned but in reality the diamond is
a fake it was replaced with a glass
replica and under this diamond is a card
of the Joker it's a Joker playing card
and so what we do is we realize that the
Joker seems to be the one that's
actually actually done this and so we
switched to the Joker himself as he's
basically mulling over what's happened
so far then what the Joker does is he
tells us how it was that he had killed
Henry Claridge what he says is that he
had injected Henry Claridge with the
time toxin 12 hours before he made his
declaration of killing him so that when
midnight struck on the night that he was
supposed to kill Henry Claridge that
Henry Claridge were in fact to drop dead
because the toxin took 24 hours to take
effect and so what the dot what the
Joker had done is he had injected Henry
Claridge and then he had taken the
diamond so that anybody who watched
Henry Claridge anybody who was with him
at the time would think there was some
kind of superstition here now the next
person that he claims to kill is a man
named Jay Wilde and what the Joker does
here is he effectively uses a different
scheme each time he kills a person when
he goes after Jay wild he's actually in
a suit of armor when he makes his
declaration when he makes his threat and
saying he will kill Jay wild and then
he'll take the Rubies of Jay wild the
police of course I'll respond to this
and when the police respond we find that
what the Joker does is he basically
begins to I guess bombard them with some
kind of toxic was I'm sorry some kind of
toxin with some kind of gas then the
result is that the police were knocked
unconscious and Jay wild is again killed
and so he takes the Rubies of Jay wild
and then he leaves and so the third
person that he threatens is the judge is
a person named judge Drake and what
happens with judge Drake is that he that
the Joker pretends to be the Chief of
Police and then basically says he's
going to be protecting judge Drake and
so what judge Drake realizes is that
this is in fact the Joker and so what
the Joker does is then again kill judge
Drake now the whole reason why judge
judge Drake is killed by the Joker is
because the Joker states that judge
Drake had previously locked him up and
so we won't actually find out into a
little while from now why it was this
had happened like what it was the Joker
was referring to in this particular
instance but the factory main
that this basically catches the
attention of Batman and Dick Grayson
because again Dick Grayson was Robin at
this particular point in time and the
Golden Age of comics and so what we do
is we pick up with Batman and Robin as
they're trying to track down the Joker
as they're chasing down the Joker
they eventually locate him and they
capture him and the signature scene and
this final comic when the Joker is
basically hanging by the edge of a
building and Batman pulls him up and
then takes him to jail now following the
initial introduction of the Joker and
going forward into the Golden Age of
comics The Joker basically became a
mainstay in Batman for about the first
12 or 13 issues or so and the reason why
was because the Joker was extremely well
received by fans fans love this idea of
a person who dressed up as a clown and
who put Batman to the test who basically
made Batman go through all the rigors of
trying to find a way to capture this
person but at the same time it was a
break away from the monotony of what
we've seen with so many different
superheroes up to this point by this
point in the Golden Age we had Batman we
had name of the Submariner from Marvel
Comics we had um we had other characters
who were coming along then who were
basically I guess fighting their own
villains of course was Superman
different things like that and so for
Batman to be among this group but to
have a villain that stood out and of
himself this was a great way for fans to
be pulled in and so what we basically
found here was that DC was hitting all
the right notes
we had Dick Grayson as Robin who was
able to identify with younger kids we
had the Joker who was able to identify
with people who wanted something
different than what they'd seen so far
and so what we found was that in 1951 I
think with Detective Comics issue number
168 that Bill Finger gives us the origin
of the Joker and what he tells us here
is that in this story which is basically
kind of a I guess a crime instruction so
to speak by Batman that is to say he's
been brought before a class for
criminology and he's teaching in the
steps of how to to basically decipher
crime scenes he recounts the story of
the Red Hood and what he tells them is
that the Red Hood was the villain that
he never caught he never found out who
the Red Hood was and he was never able
to capture the Red Hood in any form or
fashion and what he tells us is that the
Red Hood apparently was a criminal who
had undergone the process of committing
various robberies and sorts for the goal
but basically collecting 1 million
dollars and then reach
hiring from the criminal scene then so
as a result Batman had chased them down
he attract him down multiple times but
had never quite caught him and so over
the course of this story what actually
is I revealed to us is that the Red Hood
returns as a result of Batman's actions
and so because of this Batman I guess
reignites his investigation end of the
Red Hood and ultimately it's revealed to
us that the Red Hood is the Joker and
what Joker tells us in this story is
that when he and Batman had met each
other at the ACE chemical plant that he
had use his I guess uses helmet as a way
to basically breathe underwater to make
it possible for him to escape without
having to worry about drowning and when
he had jumped into the chemical VAT that
he had swam to safety and gone back home
but when he took off his helmet he had
realized that his face was bleach white
his lips were red and that his hair was
green and so his argument here was that
he could use this new mask to basically
terrify people to find a way to to
basically make them horrified at his
very presence and to also commit crimes
and so that led to the Joker to his
current point in time now a lot of
people who are more traditionalist about
the origin of Joker will cite this
origin story but most people will cite
the origin story which we'll get into
and of course you've already done a
video on that the video of the I guess
the story of The Killing Joke but
nonetheless we're getting a little ahead
of ourselves here now what we know is
that going forward with the whole Batman
continuity and the whole Joker
introduction of into the Batman story
that again the Joker was one of the very
few villains in Batman continuity that
lasted through the Golden Age and the
reason why I say this is because for
those of you guys who have seen a lot of
our videos where we've talked about the
history of Marvel and DC Comics we've
talked about the Golden Age versus the
Silver Age and characters coming up out
and different things like that when the
Golden Age began to wrap up around the
mid-1950s
comic books began to take a turn towards
science fiction romance different things
like that and very few superheroes or
super villains actually made the cut and
remained as part of the continuity of
comic books going past the Silver Age
the Joker was one of these characters
that survived but the problem was this
by 1954 things were starting to change
things were starting to move in a
different direction and so what we found
was that in that year in 1954 a man by
the name of Frederick wertham I believe
had published a book called
seduction of the innocence and what he
said here was that the problem with
comic books with all these different
forms of media television and so on that
are cropping up is that children are
more influenced now than they ever were
before and that things like comic books
violence is so on and so forth are
impacting children in a way to where it
leads to what he perceived to be
negative actions that is to say
homosexuality and different things like
that now of course we know now that this
was really more of a baseless claim and
that it's really a lot of nonsense but
the fact remains that at the time this
was extremely effective and so again in
that same year in 1954 we saw the
introduction of the comics code
Authority and what the comics code
Authority did is it basically went
through comic book publications as a
whole and said anything that contains
any kind of violence any kind of murder
any kind of I guess sexual activity is
to say anything beyond the realm of like
kissing and hand-holding is forbidden
that any criminals that exist in comic
books have to receive some kind of
punishment as a result of their actions
when the comic book comes to an end or
when the story ends and so basically we
saw that the Joker was kind of swept
under the rug
that this bill finger this Bob Kane
version of the Joker took a backseat
that he was no longer this sadistic and
I guess very very murderous kind of
villain we had seen in the early days of
his introduction and instead he became
it's very goofy character this very sort
of a silly character I guess with
regards to to why he did the kind of
things that he did now this was further
impacted in 1964 and the reason why I
say in 1964 is because at this point
Julius Schwartz had become the
editor-in-chief of DC Comics and Julius
Schwartz did not like the idea of the
Joker at all now I haven't been able to
deduce why it is or I guess be able to
find out why it is Julius Schwartz
didn't like the Joker but the fact
remains that because Julius Schwartz as
the editor-in-chief despised the Joker
what little remnants of the Joker there
currently were in DC Comics began to
fade away even more and so the Joker was
almost non-existent in DC Comics and
this is where I say we can basically
trace the popularity and the decline in
popularity of Batman comics with the
Joker's initial introduction and with
degres and it was very difficult to tell
who it was that was really leading the
popularity then Batman com
it was difficult to tell if it was the
Joker if it was Batman if it was Robin
we didn't really know who it was it was
leading the popularity but when the
Joker had moved away from his sadistic
roots and he had become very tamed down
kind of this comedic nonsensical villain
Batman sales began to decline and
because they began to decline it became
very evident who it was that was leading
the popularity of the Batman comics but
this really didn't do a whole lot to
deter Julius Schwartz from bringing I
guess from keeping the Joker away and so
what we found was that in 1966 with the
TV show Batman and with Cesar Romero
playing the role of the Joker where the
comedic version of the Joker had
basically taken a backseat and been
almost non-existent the character of the
Joker was made up for with Cesar Romero
playing his role and so what we found
was that continuing forward into DC
Comics that while the sales of that man
didn't really I guess increase that the
character of the Joker still stayed
relevant people sue remembered who he
was and so what we found was that in I
guess about 1973 or so that Dennis
O'Neil and Neal Adams had basically been
tasked with the idea of bringing the
Joker back of revitalizing the character
of the Joker and the way they had done
this was by I guess effectively looking
at the history of the Joker by looking
at Bill Finger and Bob Kane by looking
at the nonsensical Joker we got during
the age of the comic book code Authority
and so what they did is they combined
the two elements they said okay let's
take this sadistic murderous Joker and
let's combine him with the funny Joker
and let's just have this guy who's very
funny but very dangerous at the same
time and I cannot begin to tell you how
well received this was I cannot begin to
tell you it was absolutely nuts how many
fans loved this because what we found
here was a fans now had their old Joker
back they had the Joker they always
loved the Joker that would murder
arbitrarily the Joker that would kill
people the Joker that had these insane
schemes in his head but the other half
was that they got laughter out of it
they got humor out of it it was funny to
watch this back and forth between the
Joker and Batman in addition to Neal
Adams and and
and Dennis O'Neil what we found was that
in 1976 or so that Steve Englehart had
taken over the role of writing for the
Batman I'm sorry writing for the Joker
and so what he did was in Detective
Comics issues number 471 lat
what many considered to be the
quintessential Joker those of you guys
who watched Batman the Animated Series
those of you guys who remember that
version of the Joker that's Steve
Englehart Joker that's the Joker who was
incredibly insane and had insane schemes
and in fact in Detective Comics
issue number 475 I believe it was Batman
had actually made the statement and
saying that the Joker's insane schemes
make sense to no one but himself and
this single phrase this one phrase
defines the Joker better than any story
ever could
the reason being because during Steve
Englehart run we got stories like The
Laughing fish the laughing fish was
quite literally a story whereby the
Joker had given fish his signature Joker
expression the signature grin as a
result of the Joker toxin and he wanted
to copyright those fish and that's how
he was going to make his money that was
the scheme of the Joker that was his
goal there these stories these I guess
definitive attributes of the Joker are
actually what would go on to define who
the Joker would be even now with a new
52 version of the Joker but the fact
remains that by 1988 DC began to realize
that while the sales of Batman were
starting to kind of break even while
they were starting to sort of I guess
reached this plateau where they weren't
really dipping down any further they had
to do something
they had to do something to revitalize
interest and both the Joker and the
Batman stories overall and so what we
found here was that DC had come along
and DC had introduced to us the origin
story of the Joker and Alan Moore's The
Killing Joke now Alan Moore's The
Killing Joke as a which is a series that
we've already discussed a couple videos
that we've already talked about so far
are a couple or I guess is a series
whereby we learn the entire history of
the Joker at least as is given to us by
Alan Moore and this is the I guess the
origin story that a lot of Joker fans
really point to as the quintessential
origin story
the defining element origins story of
who it is that Joker is and why it is
that he does the kind of things that he
does but the fact remains here that with
this version of the Joker with this
origin story it's not concrete that even
a joker during the story itself says is
sometimes he remembers his history one
way and sometimes he remembers it
another way and because he's the one
that's narrating this story and telling
it to us he's not reliable and so DC was
basically coming out and saying that
this is not a solid story for the Joker
this is simply just an origin story and
kind of an Elseworlds imprint but that
ultimately it was rolled I guess rolled
back into the fold of DC main continuity
but the other thing DC did is they
continued to look at the idea of the
Joker and they said we need to do more
we need to do something that's going to
basically tell Joker fans that were
never going back to the comics code
version of the Joker we're never going
back to the nonsensical whimsical
version of the Joker we're going back to
a serious really sadistic and a little
comedic version of the Joker and so what
we found in the same year was that DC
launched a death in the family and a
death in the family was a huge story not
just because it involved the death of
Jason Todd which was voted on by fans
but because it forever changed the
standard of the Joker and The Killing
Joke we found the Joker had shot Barbara
Gordon that was the extent of his
involvement in attacking and hurting
members of the bat family that was as
far as it had gotten and in the death
and the family he had killed Robin he
killed Jason Todd and that was so big it
was so huge because what DC had
basically done as they had said this is
the line this right here is the line
this is the road that we've crossed
we're never going back things are never
going to be the same for the Joker and
we saw that playing out and the Joker's
continuity from that point going forward
The Joker remained sadistic the Joker
remained comedic the Joker remained this
character who was very dark and very
gritty but was so captivating at the
same time when you were reading Joker
stories you couldn't help but laugh you
couldn't help it laugh at this kind of
kind of schemes he had you couldn't help
but laugh at the back-and-forth banter
between Batman and himself he was just
that captivating not what we found going
forward was
that in 1992 that the DC had basically
rolled this version of the Joker over
into Batman the Animated Series again we
kind of talked about this earlier but
this is basically a point whereby we see
the non murderous version of the Joker
but all other elements of the Joker
being put into this character we see
that this Joker is hilarious in a lot of
different ways and even now if I go back
and watch any of the video to the Joker
from Batman the Animated Series and I
hear him laugh I laugh because to me
it's just hilarious it's just always
funny to hear that thing and again this
is how the Joker exists so how he
functions going forward but the problem
that we saw was that eventually the
Joker's continuity began to go away the
Joker had effectively just kind of
vanished from DC Comics and would
actually come back during scott Snyder's
run of Batman in a new 52 within game
but we're not going to get too far into
that the reason being is because once we
start Batman in game then wanting to get
more into that we're actually going to
get into the story of how the Joker had
vanished from DC Comics and why he
returned during the new 52 and so we're
going to do is we're going to go ahead
and cut this video here the reason being
because when we talk about characters
like the Red Hood we've talked about
that kind of stuff and so I kind of feel
like we basically be rehashing things
that we've already discussed and at this
point it's not really something that I'm
wanting to do so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video I think was a pretty
good discussion on the Joker given the
in-depth continuity and so what I'll do
is that in the comments section I'll
post what I considered to be some of the
more prominent stories of the Joker but
I consider to be some of the best
stories of the Joker and why it is he
seems to be such a significant character
in DC Comics that being said and we'll
cut you guys let him piece
you